die habe ich besorgt eine studie die die
kultusministerkonferenz vorgestellt hat
es geht um das thema lesen und schreiben
und rechnen bei unseren grundschülern
die
besorgniserregende studie hat ein
ergebnis gehabt und zwar dass
beispielsweise beim thema lesen nur noch
44 prozent der grundschüler in der
vierten klasse am ende des schuljahres
den mindest standard erreichen also
diesen den standard den man eigentlich
sowieso erreichen muss 30 schaffen
diesen standard gar nicht das bedeutet
am ende wir haben es mit 14 zu tun die
auf eine weiterführende schule kommen
und ganz ganz viele qualifikationen die
man haben sollte die man haben muss und
die man nicht nur als mindeststandards
am ende haben muss man eigentlich über
erfüllen sollte gar nicht mehr richtig
als fähigkeit erlernt haben wir können
schlechtere lesen sie können schlecht
schreiben sie können auch schlecht
rechnen und es gibt andere spannende
zahlen die wir sehen wir sehen dass es
eine inflation die bei gute abiturnoten
die 1,0 abitur haben sich innerhalb von
15 jahren achtung versechsfacht und
gleichzeitig sehen wir aber auf
internationaler ebene sind die deutschen
schüler gar nicht so gut wenn wir sehen
bei den pisa tests beispielsweise nach
den großen pisa schock anfang dieses
jahrtausends dann halten wir uns
weiterhin so ein bisschen knapp über dem
mittelfeld aber sind deutlich besser
geworden obwohl doch so viele 1,0
abiturienten mittlerweile haben also es
liegt ganz ganz viel schief hier im land
der schuldige ausgemacht meinung nach
das sind die landesregierung das sind
die kultusminister die machen die
schulen kaputt nutzen die kultusminister
und die bildungspolitik als
ideologischen experimentierkasten und
das ist am ende etwas was zu lasten
unserer kinder geht und das darf nicht
sein frau bauer die fdp als
regierungspartei was wird die fdp tun
damit sich das verbessert was sie ja
wahrscheinlich auch wollen also wir
wollen als fdp natürlich dass dieses
bildungs und überhaupt unser ganzes
bildungssystem unabhängig vom elternhaus
ist und wir müssen schon ehrlich sein
die letzten beiden jahre mit corona
haben das ganze eigentlich komplett
verschärft auch die zahlen die sie
genannt haben wurden gerade in den
beiden jahren noch mal explizit
verschärft wir hatten erst vor kurzem
den zahlen dann aber auch schon 2018
beispielsweise die waren schlecht aber
nicht so schlecht wir wissen dass ein
drittel der kinder nachholbedarf hat und
eigentlich nachhilfe bräuchten wir
wissen dass unglaublich viele junge
menschen unserem land kinder und
jugendliche an psychischen folgen leiden
und deshalb ist für uns als fdp eines
klar in diesem winter darf es nicht
wieder zu schulschließungen zu kita
schließungen kommt denn das ist die
grundlage dafür wir haben in der korona
krise gesehen wie abhängig der
schulische erfolg vom elternhaus ist und
es hat sich einfach viel zu sehr
verschärft und ja einerseits kann eine
bundesbildungsministerin die bettina
stark watzinger sehr viele software
installieren ich finde er macht sie auch
einen sehr guten job machen sie jetzt
auch sage es ist natürlich nicht nur
ihre aufgaben sondern ganz explizit und
das haben sie völlig richtig gesagt herr
scherer kommen da bund und länder
gleichermaßen in die pedale
beziehungsweise einen handlungsbedarf
die länder müssen ihre aufgabe doch noch
stärker gerecht werden auch ein stück
weit zu gucken was können sie auch
verbessern denn wir haben den eklatanten
lehrermangel wir haben den punkt dass
wir einfach auch im bildungssystem mehr
durchlässigkeit brauchen und wir
verbrauchen auf der anderen seite auch
den zugang zu neueren methoden sei es im
schulunterricht sei es im ev die methode
sind glaube ich dass sie ansprach habe
die methode die methoden sind das
problem war es nämlich nicht mehr
passiert beispielsweise nicht weiß weil
ich selbst vater von schulpflichtigen
kindern bin was nicht mehr passiert ist
beispielsweise das diktate geschrieben
werden so gut wie gar nicht mehr da kann
man sagen wenn das ein einzelfall das
gibt es in anderen bundesländern auch
diktate werden nicht mehr geschrieben
wissen aber auch aus der forschung das
permanente wiederholen der eimer ist
voll das führt dazu dass ich irgendwann
das wort der eimer und voll richtig
schreiben kann und zwar ohne h und ohne
so also das sind dinge da kann man mal
mit methoden kommen noch mehr technik
und alle brauchen ipad es geht hier
glaube ich um wirklich grundlegend es
geht auch um die frage werden noch
gedichte gelehrt nein auch so gut wie
gar nicht mehr werden noch aufsätze
geschrieben nein auch so gut wie gar
nicht mehr also ich glaube wir brauchen
gar nicht viele milliarden um zu sagen
jetzt braucht jedes kind ein ipad
sondern wir brauchen eigentlich glaube
ich die rückbesinnung auf das wie es in
der guten alten schule gewesen bin ist
ich bin den 80ern und 90ern zur schule
gegangen da war sicherlich auch schon
nicht alles gut aber nur teilweise war
in den 50ern 60ern vieles was gelehrt
wurde oder wie es gelehrt wurde viel
besser auch ein thema das thema schrift
man lernt jetzt druckbuchstaben früher
hat man schreibschrift gelernt
schwimmübungen es war doch wunderbar
wenn man sich heute schrift anguckt von
vielen menschen von vielen schülern ist
das nicht mehr richtig zu erkennen
dadurch entstehen auch fehler dadurch
sehen schüler ihre fehler selbst auch
gar nicht richtig bedeutet ich würde
gerade sagen die celtics ist das eine
das ist wichtig aber den lehrmethoden
sollten wir weg von diesen ganzen
neumodischen zeug und schreiben nach
gehör rückt zu dem was uns stark gemacht
hat also guckt in die alte zeit aber
herr schäfer darf ich sie fragen ihre
these lautet die politik macht unsere
schulen kaputt als der einzige nicht
politiker nicht politikerin von ja ich
mache ich jetzt auch nicht als politiker
bild wenn ich da ist sozusagen zu bild
und nicht zu den gästen deswegen nur
meine frage und und gar nicht nur eine
rhetorische frage warum ist es immer
noch ein tabu darüber zu sprechen dass
wir weil sie sagen die politik macht
unsere schulen kaputt dass wir endlich
wieder die schul zuständigkeit dem bund
geben warum ist das eigentlich so ein
tabu er wird was wäre so grauenvoll wenn
der bund die zuständigkeit hätte sei es
teilweise ganz
aber allein schon einheitlichkeit
bisschen mehr hat für das zentralabitur
ich habe auch schon das zentralabitur
geschrieben und jetzt habe ich mal ein
juristisches argumenten ganz politisches
argument debatte wenn sie es
verbindlichen also dem bund geben
verstaatlich ist es ja schon aber wenn
sie sozusagen den bund exklusiv geben
könnte es mehr debatten geben die
debatten finden jetzt in jedem einzelnen
bundesland stand war statt was auch sehr
schön ist und sicherlich auch spaß macht
den politikerinnen und politiker aber
wenn der bund die zuständigkeit hätte
für die schulen dann hätten wir debatten
über solche themen wollen wir das oder
wollen wir nicht wollen wir das abitur
so machen oder nicht wollen wir wieder
das dreigliedrige schulsystem wollen wir
mehr diktate jetzt findet dass irgendwo
im osnabrücker anzeiger stadt nichts
gegen den osnabrücker anzeiger aber das
wäre jetzt mal ein argument sozusagen
demokratie
nicht nur der osnabrücker es gut auch
wenn ich eigentlich meine ihren stecker
ist der wind politikchef mitglied der
chefredaktion der das thema heute
mitgebracht als es ja schon ist aber
selten aber ist mit dem sohn und schauen
millionen zu sie können mit uns jetzt
hier genau darüber diskutieren ich
glaube übrigens das ist völlig falsch
wäre wenn der bund das übernehmen würde
die frage ist ja wer regiert im bund das
sind meistens die parteien cdu csu spd
grüne fdp so und wenn ich in die
bundesländer schauen denn sich ungefähr
den gleichen mix und in den
bundesländern passiert etwas das weniger
diktate geschrieben weniger aufsätze das
bildungsniveau sinkt also wäre jetzt der
gewinn wenn der bund das machen würde
vorher war er und freundin die das sind
und vor allem kennen sie denn eigentlich
ein gedicht ich würde jetzt sagen sie
sind ja nicht als den letzten zehn
jahren abiturientin gewesen ich habe mir
das in ordnung zu sagen kennen sie noch
ein gedicht das mit eben auch
angesprochen ach ja also ich glaube
schon dass ich noch gedichte kenner ich
habe früher viel von friedrich schiller
aber den uns ja sein ich will da im
busch habe ich zu hause gelesen mein
vater hat mich viel wieder imbusch
vorgelesen aber jetzt nochmal zu dem
punkt länder oder bunt es war ja vorher
auch deutlich besser das bildungsniveau
als es auch noch ländersache war so und
da bin ich ganz bei ihnen frau schenk
ich stelle mir auch die frage ist es
denn dann jetzt beim bund besser
aufgehoben kann er das besser
entscheiden also das ist jetzt erst mal
so eine rein administrative frage die
inhaltliche frage die ist recht
interessant ja schäfer aufgeworfen hat
wir haben ja enorme defizite ich meine
was rege ich mich über rechtschreibung
und bei den kindern auf es sind genau
die gleichen beobachtungspunkte die
kinder schreiben plötzlich nach dem
gehör sie werden nicht mehr ordentlich
korrigiert und wenn sie nicht korrigiert
werden das nicht wiederholen kann die
diktate machen dann lernen sie es nicht
vernünftig und das ist etwas also da
werden defizite aufgebaut die sich
nachher gar nicht mehr korrigieren
lassen also ich frage mich wie ein
pädagogisches system das überhaupt
durchlaufen lassen kann also eigentlich
ist doch der erste schritt dass wir
sagen also eigentlich müssen wir zu den
bildungsstandards zurück ich habe auch
ich war auch in den 80er jahren in der
grundschule wenigstens mal da hin zurück
dass wir da wirklich auch mal so ich
sage es mal die grundrechenarten und
schreibschrift wieder jahren und auch
vor allem wieder diktate machen und auch
verein hängen dass die kinder vernünftig
korrigiert werden also das ist erst mal
der erste schritt wo wir wo wir zu
rücken müssen denn ja wir sind auch
nicht umsonst internationalen pisa
vergleich das sieht sich ja vor ort sind
wir so weit abgestürzt also das fängt ja
allein schon in der grundschule anja wir
sprachen über das thema handwerker zu
beginn der sendung auch mit dem hinweis
naturwissenschaften das ist da auch
immer wieder viel zu wenig
schulabsolventen gibt die das eigentlich
als ein kernthema als interessantes fach
sehen und dass da wird der grundstein ja
eigentlich auch schon gelegt wenn der
matte in der grundschule schon nicht
spaß macht oder ich per brief die ahnung
habe ich komme da gar nicht hinterher
dann zieht sich das natürlich auch
weiter durch die weiterführende schule
ob setzt das gymnasium ist oder die
realschule gemeinschaftsschule wie das
dann ja heute auch häufig heißt und ich
will das gar nicht unbedingt bei den
lehrern
ablegen weil es da glaube ich sehr sehr
viele sehr sehr engagierte lehrer gibt
die mit viel eifer dabei sind aber die
müssen halt dinge in ihren lehrplänen
umsätzen bei denen man manchmal sagen
muss tja ist das wirklich nötig brauchen
wir das erste wirklich schöne den die
lehrer verdienen in deutschland im
internationale vergleich extrem gut gibt
kaum ein land wenn ich rede ist sogar
deutschland das land das die lehrer am
besten bezahlt das eis tag ist das
niveau hier schon sehr sehr gut sind
beamte das heißt sind auch gut
abgesichert es kennt dann auch nicht
bestellt herr schäfer vollkommen richtig
es gibt auch angestellte lehrer genau in
berlin hat man jetzt auf die beamten
besondere oder grundschullehrer für
deutlich weniger
das ist in der regel auch mittlerweile
anfangen wollen das ist man kann immer
über den über das thema bezahlung reden
das ist richtig deswegen aber ich glaube
das problem ist jetzt gar nicht
unbedingt sind jetzt nicht die
lehrerinnen und lehrer sondern ist eher
das was nun umsetzen müssen was sich in
dem fall dann wieder politiker
ausgedacht haben weil sie der meinung
sind das müsste jetzt aber man kann in
berlin und das ist wir gar kein
langweilt aber ein lied davon singen wir
hatten bis zur landtagswahl im letzten
jahr eine schulsenatorin die wurde ja da
nachher per gerichtsurteil dazu
gezwungen die schulen wieder zu öffnen
berlin war das letzte bundesland was
nach dem zweiten lok da und die schulen
wieder öffnet geöffnet hat und zwar
nur wegen eines gerichtsbeschlusses weil
die eltern gesagt es kann nicht sein im
ganzen land wird unterrichtet aber in
berlin noch nicht
argument der senatorin war jedoch nur
noch drei wochen bis zu den ferien wird
da würde sich die schuleröffnung nicht
mehr lohnen so weit sind wir und diese
schulsenatorin oder politiker die machen
auch die lehrbücher den lehrplan des das
kann nicht sein händler warnen
eigentlich die schulschließung
juristisch akzeptabel
das ist natürlich ein 1 1 sehr vermintes
gelände und und auch ich hoffe sind wir
geben sich da ja ich bin relativ
furchtlos berufsbedingt aber die
wahrheit ist
und dass die antwort wird sie wird er
wird ihnen nicht passen und ist auch
nicht sehr unterhaltsam die antwort ist
es kommt drauf an
es ist wirklich so wir bewegen uns ja in
diesen ganzen corona fragen leider immer
im bereich verhältnismäßigkeit
gefürchtet von jedem jurastudenten von
jeder jurastudentin weil es eben sehr
viel argumentation abverlangt weil es
kein schema f gibt und so ist das hier
auch ich merke gerade ich antworte schon
fast jeden politiker relativ ausweichen
aber ich glaube ist es juristisch
wirklich so die schulschließungen müssen
im einzelfall unter dem grundsatz der
verhältnismäßigkeit
der informationen die die jeweilige
kommune oder das land hatte beurteilt
werden
das war echt ein politiker weil ich bin
heute enttäuscht der winkler ja ich man
muss auch
am ende kommt jetzt die große
enttäuschung aber können sie denn als
politiker als bundestagsabgeordneten
mehr als bürgerin versprechen dass die
politik zu diesem mittel nicht mehr
greifen wird und die schulen schließen
weil wir werden alles dafür tun ich
glaube das ist schon ein ganz klar dass
die bundesbildungsministerin dieses
signal in unser land sind in schulen und
kitas in diesem winter nicht wieder
geschlossen werden dürfen denn es sei
fatal für die jungen menschen für die
heranwachsenden in unserem land und vor
allem ehrlicherweise einerseits
bezüglich des bildungserfolges aber
andererseits auch den zahlreichen
psychischen folgen die mit einhergehen
die gerade in der auswertung der korona
maßnahmen an signifikanz überschritten
haben dass gerade die psychische
gesundheit
ja gar nicht so ernst genommen ich hoffe
das ist ein ort und wenn ich etwas
überspitzt sage ja auch noch mehr über
hätte ich mache kein hehl daraus dass
die ngp nicht immer die ausführungen von
herrn lauterbach teilen kann und kein
fan app kein fan aber nichtsdestotrotz
ist es auch wichtig hin zu gucken die
auswertung hat stattgefunden ist
wissenschaftlich fundiert und danach
müssen wir ganz klar schulen und kitas
offen halten für den bildungserfolg
unsere heranwachsenden generation aber
auch für die psychische gesundheit
unserer gesellschaft denn wir können gar
nicht all diese fälle aktuell in
irgendeiner weise überhaupt in eine
behandlung geben ganz viele in unserem
land fehlen zahlreiche psychologen
landauf landab des kinderpsychologen
sind oder wachsein psychologen auch da
müssen wir uns mal überlegen inwiefern
wir die psychologische ausbildung auf
stärken können gerade diese klinische
psychologe aufwendiges ich glaube vor
allem auch das wieder länder thematik
deshalb auch das was sie versprochen
haben ist auch viel länder thematik
bezüglich lehrinhalte methoden und so
weiter und so fort nein aber wie viele
plätze sind denn dann im masterstudium
überhaupt fit beim bayern sind es 100
plätze für die absolventen aus dem
bachelor studium als 100 potenzielle
klinische absolventen im
masterstudiengang das reicht aktuell
überhaupt nicht aus und es ist in allen
bundesländern ähnlich und da glaube ich
muss mal auch die diskussion zu
überführen